Behind me is HMS Defender, one of the new
generation of Royal Navy ships. It is an incredible
piece of engineering, capable of taking out
a small drone at 40km distance, capable of
tracking 2,000 targets at once.
'Cos it's a destroyer, and it is meant to
defend itself and the rest of the fleet by
taking out incoming missiles before they even
come close. It is a masterpiece of modern
warfare engineering.
[MUSIC: Rule Britannia]
But like all big ships, it has a design flaw
that you really can't get around -- as long
as you're building something out of steel.
If you take that much metal, and put it through
a big magnetic field -- like, say, the Earth's,
as it sails around -- then it's going to start
picking up magnetism. It's going to start
diverting compasses. It's going to start being
detected by magnetic mines, which were developed
during World War 2 and afterwards to home
in on any big source of magnetic signals -- like,
say, a ship that's been sailing for a while
-- and detonate next to them.
We're talking sea mines here, by the way,
not land mines.
So how do you defend against that? Well, nowadays
you use very complicated degaussing equipment
on board a ship. But in the past, you used
to drag a 2,000 amp electrical cable down
the side, or set up an enormous degaussing
coil that is bigger than the ship itself,
and -- well, do the same thing that you used
to do to CRT monitors when you pushed a button
and they went 'dong' and distorted for a while.
But what if you want to get close to a mine?
What if your ship's job is to get rid of mines,
and you need to get close enough to spot them
without setting them off?
Docked just downriver from Tower Bridge is
this: HMS Middleton, a Hunt-class mine countermeasures
vessel. It's a minesweeper, bascially, which
means it can tell how many mines are in adjacent
grid squares -- no, I'm kidding. It seeks
out and destroys mines.
But it's able to do that without the mines
detecting it and detonating it because this
is not made of metal.
This ship is made of glass-reinforced plastic.
It's able to find and destroy mines that are
hunting for magnetic things because, well,
it's not made of anything magnetic. It's just
a plastic boat.
Sounds terrible when I put it like that, but
well: this class of vessel can do more damage
to one specific threat
than anything else in the Royal Navy.
[Translating these subtitles? Add your name here!]